the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group you can't do it
vanessa you cannot hack into the nevada
voting machine system
you just can't do it tonight on politics
now
keeping your ballot safe the head of the
las vegas fbi field office tells us
about security
for election day nevadans love to vote
early how a pandemic and mail-in ballots
are all affecting voter turnout this
year plus
meet nicole canicero cannizzaro wrote
legislation to raise her own pay
by 150
an effort by republicans to unseat state
senate majority leader nicole canozzaro
from eight news now this is politics now
securing the november election thank you
for joining us here on politics now i'm
john langler we are 10 days away from
election day
this week the fbi announced efforts by
iran and russia to influence the
election
election officials and law enforcement
say measures are in place to prevent
problems the i-team's vanessa murphy
talked with the local head of the fbi
nevada voters may be dropping off their
mail-in ballots at early voting
locations like this
one or casting their ballots at these
locations
and there's a lot of misinformation
floating around
about this election the head of the
local fbi office says voters should feel
confident though and any issues will be
investigated
because of the robust protections for
voting here in nevada it's really hard
to get away with anything
president donald trump continuously
questions the integrity of the november
election
even saying governor steve sisilak will
steal it
one concern mail-in ballots election
officials insist
signature verification helps eliminate
voter fraud
is it widespread in nevada i wouldn't
say it's widespread
i would say that we get reports every
year every election cycle
of potential voter fraud situations and
we investigate them thoroughly
and we hold the people if it's if it's
proven then we hold them accountable
through the u.s attorney's office
as the i-team has reported data reveals
only two votes in nevada have been cast
illegally since 2008.
rauf says the fbi will investigate any
allegations of fraud or voter
intimidation
now end on november 3rd he also tells
the i-team he has
confidence in the voting machines since
they are not part of a network
and have no internet connection were
there attempts
to hack into our system here you can't
do it vanessa you cannot hack into the
nevada
voting machine system you just can't do
it 100 percent
you would have to you would have to go
machine by machine
and that is just not feasible what is a
concern
interference from abroad foreign
adversaries from
multiple countries are keen on
undermining people's confidence in the
election and so they do that
utilizing social media the internet and
they put
out sometimes it appears to be
legitimate stories
or they put out memes that people glom
on to
that make them think that the elections
somehow going to be illegitimate
president trump has suggested voting
twice by mail
and in person to test this system rouse
says
don't do that it's a crime vanessa
murphy
8 news now statewide early end mail and
voting has been underway for two weeks
here in clark county through thursday
there were 168 thousand people who voted
early
there's still another week of in-person
early voting
162 thousand mail-in ballots have been
received in clark county where democrats
have a three-to-one advantage in-person
votes here have been split
about 50 50. there's a slight 3 000 vote
lead for republicans
so far about 58 000 more democrats than
republicans have voted
in clark county all right so let's take
a little bit of a look at how that
compares historically to early voting
here in clark county
so here's a look at a chart here and in
clark county it's been more than
half of the turnout and it's gone up
every year you can see here from
1996 all the way to 2016 here
the trend going way up and it's been
like that as you can see from 96 up to
uh
2016. almost two thirds of our votes for
the last few election cycles
have been early votes clark county is
disputing meanwhile an allegation
it's not allowing ballot observers the
public has a legal right to observe the
ballot counting process
president trump and the republican party
sent a letter to the secretary of state
and it claims that election officials
did not allow them to observe the
process
however clark county says it's gone
above and beyond it added the trump
campaign was allowed in but were turned
back because they tried to use the
camera inside
it's against nevada law to take pictures
or videos where ballots are counted
between potential legal challenges and
threats of misinformation from
foreign countries there are voters maybe
you in particular might be concerned
about the election
we spoke with david becker he's the
executive director and founder of the
center for election innovation and
research
and he's a cbs news contributor
we spoke with the unusc rather
election cyber security initiative and
what they were talking about maybe you
would agree is
the actual process of voting and the
ballot itself
is secure it's the misinformation that
is
or the information that is insecure but
i guess the question is though
is it illegal is it against the law to
put out misinformation especially since
voter information as you point out is
publicly available so of course it can
be against the law to spread
disinformation about the election
process
certainly there are international uh
laws that govern this as well and we
should be very wary
when someone like russia or iran tries
to attack our sovereignty by interfering
in our elections
and that's exactly right the goal of
these adversaries
it's not necessarily to change votes
that's almost impossible to do
in an undetected way we've not seen any
evidence of that whatsoever
but what they can get us to do is to
distrust our own election process to
delegitimize the election
itself to reduce voter confidence which
will delegitimize our elected leaders
and weaken our democracy and the best
thing we can do as american voters is to
show up in record numbers
there's nothing vladimir putin would
hate more than to see
record voter turnout in the united
states in this upcoming election
i get the sensation when election day is
over that doesn't mean it's going to
stop
that doesn't mean the the legal
challenges to the election
necessarily go away and the
misinformation goes away
what are you seeing from your point of
view with regards to
after november third and a league and
law
so i think i think we're very likely to
know the result of the presidential
election
either by wednesday morning or
a day or two after that because of the
very high turnout that we're likely to
see the more people who turn out the
less likely we're going to have the
really really narrow margins
where we get into a possible
post-election litigation scenario
is similar to 2000 where we've got one
or two states that have essentially
decided the presidency
and the margins in those states are
razor thin we remember in florida in
2000 it was 537 votes
but you know if we get even one percent
margins in faith that's actually a
rather large margin to my knowledge
there's never been
a an election result overturned a
statewide election result overturned in
the united states
where there's been a thousand vote
margin
one thing you do not see on the ballot
this year competitive third-party
candidates
unlea politics political science
professor dan lee says that's because of
how polarized the two major political
parties have become
i asked him to explain his theory i
imagine it goes both ways you talk about
the potential for the libertarians to
pull away from a more
maybe right-leaning candidate but
there's also not as
highly publicized a green party
candidate either that could do the same
to the left no
right no that's exactly right well so in
nevada you don't even have that option
because there's another hurdle for third
party candidates is the ballot access so
the third part the green party was not
able to gain ballot access in nevada
they needed to collect around 10
000 signatures which is relatively high
compared to other states
um but i think this actually highlights
an important
point about third parties is where third
parties don't
necessarily need to win elections to
influence american politics
right so for instance the green party
why aren't why is there a ceiling to the
green party
so one reason is that the democratic
party has co-opted
uh environmental positions right they've
kind of moved horse a left
on you know on the environment over the
past couple of decades
and that's eating away at the support
for green party candidates
but you see like how the green party
influenced politics though
it pulled the democratic party to the
left
when you're talking about the the green
new deal the uh
uh ocasio-cortez uh that sort of branch
of the
of the house of representatives that's a
way to in your
you're suggesting placate to some extent
to that
element of the of the population exactly
and i think what we're seeing more now
is where these outsiders are trying to
work their way through the major parties
they're not necessarily so bernie
sanders
always ran and for the house and senate
as an independent
but um for the presidency he chose to
run through the democratic party to try
to transform it
and in a lot of ways he was successful
you know he pulled clinton towards the
left in 2016.
he's kind of continued that trend to
this current election cycle actually
changed some of the
uh the rules at the democratic national
convention like with the super delegates
so he
it's you know actually transforming the
democratic party
likewise for trump an outsider in a lot
of ways he and parole are very similar
he decided to run through the republican
party to transform that party
for his uh for his political gain we
have the entire discussion there about
third party candidates if you'd like to
see it
at eightnewsnow.com all right so let's
take a look now at a couple of the
nevada
down ballot races being hotly contested
for november
state senate majority leader nicole
cannizzaro is facing some very stiff
competition from republican april becker
for state senate district six becker has
been running ads criticizing a
legislative pay hike
meet nicole cannizzaro
[Music]
wrote legislation to raise her own pay
by
150 percent all right so that is an ad
obviously and it refers to a senate
joint resolution in the 2019 legislative
session
it would have created annual legislative
sessions instead of every two years
and it also included a 150 percent pay
raise
the bill never came up for a vote
canazarro's been running ads meanwhile
against becker as well
becker's campaign is backed by
politicians who would repeal obamacare
dropping protection azaro's ads have
focused on becker's opposition as you
hear there to obamacare
and highlighting canazarro's work in the
clark county district attorney's office
she is the first female senate majority
leader in nevada history
democrats hold a 40-32 voter
registration advantage in district six
there are four clark county commission
seats up for grabs but only one of them
is expected to be close
and that is county commission district c
that seat pits republican las vegas
councilman stavros anthony against
democratic former secretary of state
ross miller
the seat is currently held by larry
brown who is terming out
the county commission right now it's all
democrats if anthony wins though he'd be
the first republican on it since bruce
woodbury left
back in january of 2009. anthony has
vowed
not to vote for any tax hikes miller
says he's the right person to lead an
economic recovery and he wants to make a
difference on the local level
you can watch interviews with those
candidates and a whole lot more over at
eight newsnow dot com
just look at the 2020 election
interviews tab
five ballot questions and five potential
changes to nevada's constitution
it restores accountability transparency
and oversight
we're going to walk you through the
ballot questions about the university
system same-sex marriage
pardons voting and renewable energy
welcome back to politics now
there are five statewide ballot
questions on your ballot this year
and these would make changes to nevada's
constitution all five have either gone
through the legislature or
gotten required signatures and they
would take effect november 24th if
they're passed
so we're going to go through all five of
those measures eight news now anchor
brian loftis starts with question one
ballot question one is probably the most
confusing one
it would remove the board of regents
from the state constitution
the board of regents oversees nevada's
university system
critics say this has allowed the board
of regents to operate without any
oversight
from the legislature former assemblyman
elliot
anderson wrote question one restores
accountability transparency and
oversight
you know right now nevada spends 1.2
billion dollars on higher ed
but without any real oversight on how
that money is spent it would also
let the legislature create new rules and
laws overseeing
nevada's higher education system it's
really really
important for nevada and for our economy
that our higher ed system can be nimble
to answer
the issues that we need to deal with
question one
has some opposition from current members
of the board of regents
but the argument against the passage on
the secretary of state's website says
question one is nothing but the
legislature trying to gain more power
and control
and it would only serve to add political
pressures to a governance system that is
serving this state well
brian loftus eight news now and up next
question two dealing with same-sex
marriage it would remove language from
the nevada constitution which says
marriage is between a man and a woman
same-sex marriage is already legal
nationwide of course and
in nevada because of a supreme court
decision
by the supreme court of the u.s back in
2015
passing question 2 would not change
marriage at all
andre wade with the silver state
equality group says it's about removing
unenforceable discriminatory language so
removing that language by voting yes on
question
2 will uphold civil rights and uphold
equality
here in the state of nevada which we
know that we stand for
an opposition statement posted in the
secretary of state's digest calls the
measure unnecessary
and calls domestic partnerships a viable
option for same-sex couples in nevada
meanwhile question three deals with the
pardons board the board gets about 15
requests for pardons a year
ryan loptis explains the changes the
measure would create
question three deals with the state
pardons board and the power
it has so first what does the pardons
board do
it does not erase a conviction but it
will restore certain rights to a pardon
felon
such as serving on a jury and gun
ownership right now the pardons board is
made up of the governor
the attorney general and the supreme
court justices
added to the state constitution require
the board to meet quarterly
allow anyone on the board to bring up
items for discussion
right now just the governor can do that
removes a requirement for the governor
to vote yes
for a pardon to be granted that had
effectively served as a veto
the argument for is the board will meet
more frequently and timely
and a pardon would not just be on the
whims of the governor the argument
against is that the board would meet
even if there are not qualified
applicants
and questioning why we would take away
the veto power of the governor
when they have it over bills from the
legislature
there is no question five so the last
two ballot questions are four and six
both would take something that's already
in state law and enshrine it in the
constitution
question four puts the voters bill of
rights in the state constitution and
includes guarantees
like the ability to vote without being
intimidated threatened or coerced
being allowed to vote on election day if
you're in line before the polls close
and requesting assistance with voting if
necessary
ballot question 6 puts the 50 by 30
renewable energy portfolio standard in
the state constitution
that would require 50 of nevada's energy
come from renewable resources by
2030. if approved all these measures
would go into the constitution
on november 24th coming up next on
politics now confirming the next supreme
court justice
coming up next when a vote on amy coney
barrett's nomination is expected to
happen next week
you're watching politics now
the u.s senate now gearing up to confirm
president donald trump's supreme court
nominee amy coney barrett
she passed the senate judiciary
committee on thursday democrats
boycotted the vote but republicans were
able to pass it anyway
a final vote of her full of the full
senate rather honor confirmation is
expected on monday
a deal on another coronavirus relief
package could be within reach
both sides on capitol hill say a deal is
possible
house speaker nancy pelosi says the
massive stimulus package would send more
checks to americans
provide money to safely reopen schools
and fund
additional covid19 testing and treatment
joining us now to talk about the
prospects of a new economic relief
package in our washington dc
bureau we have alexander limon from
washington dc alex good to see you
let's talk about what's happening with
the what's called the skinny relief bill
now working its way through the senate
the senate republicans
actually tried to call for a vote on it
earlier this week and it's really a
slimmed down
version as the name implies of the
relief package
it would have included about 500 billion
dollars in aid
but it basically went nowhere quickly it
needed
60 votes to get through the senate and
it did not get that
and democrats basically said they're
unwilling to support a skinny bill
because it's a
you know just too skinny for them it
doesn't include enough relief and enough
of the help that they want so that went
nowhere
uh senate republicans also tried to
separately call for a vote for more ppp
funding those small business loans that
have been very popular
but that also was not approved where are
negotiations
is there a stalemate between both houses
is there a stalemate between all the
parties involved here
you know it's interesting because i feel
like we've been through this time and
time again but
just this week we heard both speaker
pelosi and the white house saying that
they're very optimistic
that they feel they're very close to a
deal that could be hashed out any day
now
there's still a lot of differences that
they can't agree on and one of them
one of the big ones is whether to
include money for state and local
governments
so again this could be one of the big
hiccups that prevents this deal from
getting passed
and getting approved by at least the
house
and the white house um another thing is
that
protection from for businesses if they
face any coronavirus related lawsuits
that's another major point of
disagreement between both sides so
you know we'll have to see what happens
but they're saying they hope they can
reach a deal in a matter of days
we'll see whether they can actually get
the senate republicans
on board though and that was alexander
limon from washington d.c
welcome back to politics now hey if you
check out eight newsnow dot com
check out the election 101 tab there you
see it right there
our investigative team did an in-depth
look at the things you need to know on
your ballot
about taking part in the election uh
security all sorts of issues that maybe
you have questions about
to take part in the november election
just head to 8newsnow.com look for
election 101
you'll get all the details that you need
to take part we hope you
check it out okay now in what to watch
we're keeping an eye on the early voting
totals
that should be next week traditionally
democrats have had a voter advantage in
early voting
and republicans have done better on
election day coupling that with
complaints from
president trump and the republican party
about mail-in voting
we are watching to see if republicans
make up some of the advantage during
in-person voting
during the next week don't forget we
have put all of the interviews that we
have with all of the candidates that are
running for
offices across nevada over at eight
newsnow dot com it is under the 2020
election interviews tab check them out
before you vote sit down with your
ballot look at the interviews
see what you need to see and remember to
take part in the election
election day as you may know by now is
november 3rd
and again that election 101 section of
the website is available it has all the
other questions not just about the
candidates but about the process itself
thank you for watching politics now
we'll see you next week take care